trying to land your first Cloud job as a  woman in Tech well here are your five  tips number one don't let myths stall  your career embark on your Cloud Journey  if that's your calling don't let anybody  tell you otherwise number two Define  your focus area it could be a  specialization or a big picture  generalist if you're not sure just start  with the fundamentals and as you get  deeper you'll find your column for a  specific Focus area number three build a  support and find a good Mentor now join  communities like women Tech makers women  who code women in cloud and even reach  out to folks you admire on social media  Networks number four don't let  self-doubt get in the way know that what  you bring to the table is important and  unique and let that Propel your journey  and number five and this is the most  important one and my favorite you have  to stay authentic be you and that's just  enough